would you ever think about what made you
who you are as an individual say your
personality are you shy
mental health and illness you get
depressed often
cognitive abilities how well did you do
at school
when you think about it you usually
think of things like
your upbringing your school your friends
these are all things that you can see
and feel
but what i'm going to be talking about
is something that you can't experience
directly
dna so what i'm going to be telling you
about today
is that about my book and it's
basic messages that inherited dna
sequences are the major
systematic source making us who we are
as individuals
and the first part of my talk is about
why dna matters and then the second part
is about the dna revolution
the book is the culmination of my 45
years of research trying to understand
the genetic
and environmental sources of differences
between
individuals and after 45 years of
research
i've come to this conclusion it's stated
a bit provocatively here
but that dna is the major systematic
force
making us who we are as individuals the
word systematic is important
this research says that environment is
very important as well
but the environment works very
differently from the way we thought it
worked it's
not systematic so that's why i end up
concluding
inherited dna differences which is what
i mean by genetics
is the major systematic force making us
who we are as individuals
and when i was in graduate school 45
years ago
environmentalism the view that we are
what we learned so dominated psychology
genetics was not even mentioned you
could look at textbooks at that time in
the 70s and look up schizophrenia and
you'd be told
it's caused by what your mother did to
you in the first few years of life
and genetics wasn't ever mentioned so
after 44 decades of research
most scientists have come to conclude
that
there's a lot of evidence for the
importance of genetics
most people understand what you mean
when you say something's heritable
we're talking about individual
differences we're not talking about
innate instincts or something we're
talking about why you're different from
other people so
eye color is i color heritable i've done
lots of surveys
and you know people are pretty close to
the truth that it's almost
completely heritable meaning the
differences in whether you have green
eyes or blue eyes is largely due to what
you inherit
no problem there but when you get to
complex traits say like weight
other people who think there are no
genetic influences on weight
no one's admitting to that anyway and
50. well it's good most people guess on
average in populations
it's about 30 40 percent is what people
think but they're underestimating
genetic influence by half
and again what this means is of the
difference between us and weight
about 60 70 of the differences
are due to inherited dna differences and
that's really important because you know
in this fat shaming world of ours
people like me who always have problems
with weight putting it on too easily
finding it too hard to take it up
um you know you think just pull up your
socks willpower
yeah that's great for your skinny people
but you know for some people
in a fast food nation where you're
bombarded with food cues it's easier
said than done
you know just in a weak moment you just
eat what's around you don't notice it
that sort of thing
so it is important to recognize that
most of the differences between people
for weight
are due to inherited dna differences
that's in the populations we study
so i'll tell you in a minute there's a
lot of caveats here
and what about school achievement you
know an even more complex trait
20 yeah i mean most people the average
estimate in the population
would be 30 so that was great to hear
that because the answer is about 60
percent of the differences between kids
in school achievement from the earliest
school grades to gcses and a levels
about sixty percent of the differences
are due to inherited dna differences
and that's huge you know it's not a
hundred percent but
in the behavioral sciences if we explain
five percent of the variance that's
amazing
so explaining sixty percent of the
variance is really extraordinary
especially when
the field of education totally ignores
genetics you don't read anything about
genetics in textbooks other than
you know really rare single gene
disorders which as a teacher you'd never
see anyway
so uh
this is the most misunderstood concept
in genetics heritability
so we know what we mean when we say
heritable eye color weight
school achievement we're talking about
differences between people
but you scratch the surface of what
people know and they really don't get it
so it's worth a minute or so
explaining what we mean by heritability
we're talking about differences between
people so when we say weight is
heritable
we don't mean say if it's 70 heritable
we don't need i'm american so i still am
afraid i do pounds but
my 250 pounds i it doesn't mean
that you know 200 pounds came from my
jeans and the other 50 pounds were added
by the environment
it sounds silly but you'd be surprised
you scratch the surface of what people
know and that's what they think
nothing to do with one individual we're
talking about a population
and why people in the population differ
from each other
which is a completely different issue
and it's a
um you know we have three billion base
pairs of dna in this double helix
of dna three billion and 99 of them are
identical for all of us
so we can now sequence dna and you find
99 were exactly the same
that's what makes us human the one
percent that differs though
we can say doesn't make a difference and
that's what we're doing here we're
saying
of the differences in any trait you know
from weight to
school achievements schizophrenia
alcoholism to what extent do the
inherited
dna differences that one percent of dna
make a difference in a particular trait
we want to study
and i'll be focusing on behavioral
traits because i'm a psychologist
but we could say the same thing we could
do a talk on medical it'd be basically
the same issue
and there's several important caveats
here the first is that we're describing
a particular population so
i do studies of all the twins born in
england and wales
that's the population we study we can
only talk about describing the genetic
and environmental influences on this
population
with its mix of genetic and
environmental influences
we're not talking about what could be
we're not saying
in some other culture in some other time
in some other imaginary world
what could happen anything could happen
we're talking about what
is rather than what could be and second
we're talking about the normal range of
variation which is all we can study
so in our twin studies we probably have
95 of the population we study these kids
from birth
through birth records but you could well
imagine a very abusive
parent for example wouldn't participate
in the study even though we
we get most of the range but we can only
study what we've studied we're
describing what is
similarly we're not just we're not
studying the extremes of genetic
variation
so there are most single gene mutations
are rare
fortunately and on average maybe one in
fifty thousand one in
two hundred thousand so even in our
sample of ten thousand pairs of twins
you just don't get much of that so
they don't account for much okay so the
point here is we're studying individual
differences in a population rather than
one individual
and we're saying on average in that
population how much is weight
due to inherited dna differences and how
much due to the environment even though
the environment is varying wildly some
people like me are constantly on diets
until we're not and you know and there's
all sorts of environmental variation
out there in terms of your diets so a
lot more to say about all of these
things but
i'll just tell you a bit about some of
the methods that have been used to
estimate how important genetics is so a
century-old method is the twin method
it's like a biological experiment
i'm sure everyone knows there are two
types of twins identical and
non-identical twins
so one percent of all births are twins
and a third of those
are what we call identical or
monozygotic
in their that's a a separate an egg
that's fertilized with sperm
that zygote then sometimes we don't know
why
splits in two those two
zygotes are genetically identical they
have the same dna
information so that's why we are clones
and the other type of twin is like any
brother and sister who happen to be
conceived at the same time so very often
women have more than one egg that comes
down
and gets fertilized so like any brother
and sister
they're 50 similar genetically
and you know they they're also born in
the same womb at the same time so
they're a good control
for identical twins so it's like a
natural
quasi-experiment it's not experimental
in the sense we don't randomly assign
kids to be
identical or non-identical twins but if
a trait
is influenced by genetics you'd have to
predict
that the identical twins will be more
similar than the fraternal twins because
they're twice as similar genetically
you can use the extent to which
identical twins are more similar than
fraternal twins
to estimate heritability
so if a trait were 100 heritable like
height almost
is it's like 90 heritable you'd expect
identical twins to be almost identical
and non-identical twins not to be zero
but to be more like fifty percent or
in this case forty five percent so that
suggests there's a lot of heritability
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description
below or visit iai.tv for more debates
and talks from the world's leading
thinkers on today's biggest ideas